I think the main thing is just trying to
stay calm because certainly in Chester
there's a lot of tilt it definitely
applies more to Blitz and certainly to
bolts than say Rapid or classical but
the main thing is always just trying to
stay calm because it's very easy to tilt
and lose the game in like 20 seconds
like Andrew for example in his match
against Daniel there were a couple times
where it seemed like he was getting
close and then like he lost the game and
he instantly lost that next game in like
20 seconds uh purely due to tilt so
certainly the main thing is just to try
and stay calm and not lose your minds
it's very very easy and bullet because
you only have one minute for the whole
game just like Blitz out 20 moves get a
losing position and then just just like
that you can ruin the match so she will
repertoire change much between uh bullet
some rapid chess it depends on the
player I think that some of the openings
that I'm able to use say against Jose or
against Amino hanyan for example uh
probably would not working as a player
like Andrew Tang uh very specifically
some players I try to avoid it but for
the most part there isn't a huge
difference between Blitz and bull
between classical and Rapid it's massive
and I think that certainly there are a
lot of openings that In classical chess
I would just never never use a bullet
for sure